not completely bought out of it so one
thing about where I'm what I'm studying
I cannot stand the hatred of what this
men all the time being the reason for
everything being terrible I feel like
you guys get a very bad rep and there's
no communication as everything is always
your guys's fault and that reductive uh
um view on life does not actually get us
anywhere so in that respect I agree with
you that men are not listened to at all
in a lot of areas to the point where I
feel like there's going to be no men
left in Academia other than like
engineering and Sciences there's no
nobody is going to be wanting to study
literature because what we're talking
about is it's just degrading them in a
way that is it's just terrible